[Music]
hi everyone that was almost perfect
pronunciation I would say so thanks for
that first time I heard like that but uh
hello everyone
um I'm super happy to be here on this
stage today and to be honest it's not so
often to play an expert for nine minutes
this is the time that we are getting
so if I make any mistake in English
pretend that it's part of the show Okay
so let's start for those who don't know
me uh I flew here from Warsaw from
Poland and I have more than 10 years
experience in in banking in finance in
digital uh in digital Banking and fact
fact about me when I received last year
an email from Stanford staff that I
finished the program four hours later my
son was born and since then I'm also a
part-time horse
so uh this is my additional job so I
jump from salid to being a parent so
let's start with this big word
Innovation how many of of your companies
have innovation in the strategies
probably most of you right but what
really doesn't mean Innovation for each
person it's something different right so
my question is if you need to be the
first do you need to be an Innovative
company to win the market and I dare to
say that it's not always the
precondition to win the market
so I will give you a couple of examples
and what is innovation for example in
the industry that I work for and there's
a lot of fintech companies that they are
saying that are Innovative but for me
there were only four four Innovations in
in finance first one
it was hard cash which replaced the bar
exchanging uh system right bartender
then there were cards who replaced the
hard cache the third one it was the
Mobile Banking and digital money that
replaced the cards and the fourth
Innovation it's still questionable it's
crypto so we have four really big
Innovations in in payments right
so
if you are not Innovative company what
you can do and there is this saying that
you should create a new category within
existing Trend so what does it mean
creation of the new category I will give
you a couple of examples
the first one Red Bull
famous drink for all the students right
so not many people know that before the
pandemic hit in 2020 Red Bull captured
more than 70 percent of the energy drink
market and Red Bull wasn't the first
energy drink on the market right but the
Red Bull now it's a synonym of energy
drink
another example Apple 13 years after
they released a iPhone they captured
more than 65 percent of the market value
of touchscreen phones and of course
iPhone wasn't the first smartphone to be
honest they create a category of
smartphones to be honest with an iPhone
and again they weren't the first ones
right
the third example
is Airbnb and again just before the
pandemic because pandemic changed a lot
Airbnb has a staggering 91 share of
peer-to-peer lodging category right and
guess what people are renting their
Apartments before Airbnb came to the
market so again those three examples
that I'm showing they were not
first on the market with their services
they changed something what was already
existing they match the big Trend and
they win the market they create a
category and make it more popular right
so I like to call those companies are
category Kings and the category Kings
they became also a synonym of the
category they create we say we go for a
Starbucks coffee we may end up in other
coffee place but we go for Starbucks
let's have a Netflix night I can end up
on Disney Plus Hulu or anywhere else but
the synonym of streaming it's Netflix
right the same can be with any other
let's I Googled it not necessarily I use
Google to search it's a general term for
searching on the web right
so I am bringing also one example from
my country from Poland the company that
I'm working for
it's called Blick it's a mobile payment
it's quite similar to venmo that you
have in States and we launch in like
seven years ago in 2015 and it's an
account to account Mobile payment system
and you can imagine okay money transfer
existed before that right but after
seven years every more than every second
transaction in Poland between mobile
devices are on us
so again we weren't the first ones but
we create a category of mobile payments
so people when they send money like in
stage they said venmo this money to me
we say duplicate to me right so again we
create a category within existing trend
so what is important to underline that
people mix category creation with first
mover Advantage right so category
creation you don't need to be the first
you don't need to bring brand new things
to the market you need to make it smart
in different way than others right so a
couple of examples iPod
maybe some of you still remember it it
wasn't the first MP3 player
it became super popular when the iPod
came to the market again Apple wasn't
the first right another example Facebook
it wasn't the first the most popular
social network now Facebook is somehow
fading but it is a synonym of the social
network Friendster was before Myspace
was before right they took it a lot of
from them and they made it in different
way they created a category of social
network right again Dell many people
think that the first personal computer
was put together by Dell and there's a
lot of different companies that they did
it before right
so
coming back to the example from Poland
about Blake how you create a new
category within existing Trend and what
we did with mobile payments as an
example we saw three different things
that we addressed first heavily
fragmented ecosystem so you go to the
checkout online you say you see so many
different payment methods right you pay
different online differently in the shop
differently ATM recover that
uh this excessive amount of applications
on your devices right you need to
download venmo you need to download
PayPal and so on like you have too many
of them on your devices
and then of course there's no system
that is immune to the to the security
Bridges right so creating a new app it
means that you need to build the trust
from scratch so what we did and what we
saw that the payment fragmentation is a
new normal right so people have problem
with choosing the right payment method
and also for the merchants it's also
problematic to find which method they
should accept right
so what we did and you look at this this
is Blick it's just a six digit code it's
temporary code for payment initiation
right inside the mobile banking app and
you think is it Innovative I dare to say
it's not and I work there right for many
people it is but it's super simple you
just rewrite this code on the POS
terminal ATM or online right and this
code is serving more than half of Mobile
payment transactions in Poland right and
you had those mobile transactions before
so what we did
it's completely embedded so you don't
need to download additional app
it's inside your mobile banking app that
you already have on your phone
there's no steps to register because we
don't create additional account we are
reusing the account that it's already
done inside your mobile banking app
plus it's a seamless user experience
because user doesn't need to learn the
new interface to use it
so what is the scale right now of of our
our company like imagine 10 friends that
they are using mobile banking apps right
and in Poland six of them are using
Blick and again it wasn't the first
mobile payment method important but we
did it differently than others right and
we leveraged already existing
Clearinghouse so for many people they
call it an innovation but if you are in
the industry and you will see every
other country have a similar solution
right so if you think also about online
payments every second transaction is on
us it's of course it's not a scale of
apple or Airbnb or Red Bull but within
Poland we are category makers thanks to
us my grandmother knows about Blake my
parents know about this and my friends
also and what I want to say within those
ending nine minutes
I want to come back and all of you come
back home and think that you don't need
to be the first you don't need to be the
most Innovative you don't need to bring
totally new things you don't need to
kill yourself to find the things that
they don't exist maybe there's some kind
of gap on the market within the existing
Mega Trend that you can address
differently and they can win the market
and there are a lot of other examples so
let's make new categories and I hope
many of you will create and those are
the contact details thanks a lot
[Applause]
[Music]